sowohl meine liebe freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem video über die
geilste gta 5 map dies jeden minecraft
versicherte erinnern können aber ich
habe damals schon mal ein clash of
plants video hochladen was auch von
diesen typen derartigen jet schreibt von
nfc also von nick heißt der meine ich er
hat ja mit seinem team auch also das
sind die leute die ihr quartier drauf
sind hat er dieses diesem abgebaut diese
clans web und jetzt ist er gerade dabei
eine gta map zu zeigen und ich bin
einfach mal wieder auf den server drauf
gegangen weil ich mit denen wir uns ein
bisschen kontakt stehe und habe dann
einfach mal so ein bisschen nachgefragt
so hey was geht in der sie ja wer mich
erschlagen mehr gesehen ich sehe ja wie
sieht es denn aus mit der gleichen sache
baute der immer noch dran und es fertig
und die haben das fände ich also es wird
irgendwie übermorgen oder so auch noch
ein video zu dieser clash of plants map
kommen aber da meinten die gerade so ja
wir haben die map hier nicht auf einem
server war über die komplette gt am ätna
kennt wahrscheinlich immer diese pseudo
manhattan new york labs wo dann
irgendwie nur ein kleiner teil gebaut
ist was die grad machen übrigens jeder
der gta 5 kennt weiß dass ich gerade am
flughafen bin
die denken sich einfach nur soja
komplette welt von und das ganze mega
detailgetreuer so hier sind halt so
strenge darstellen und alles wenn ihr
euch fragt warum ihr dieser bunte gleich
ist das müssen die quasi noch pause die
haben hier schon diese ganzen
lagerhallen gebaut für diese ganzen
flugzeuge die hier wo jetzt nach ja wo
die ganzen flugzeuge halt rein kommen
die haben hier wirklich so detail sachen
wie beispielsweise diese wägelchen die
es hier gibt das ganze ist so riesig
dass es einfach eins zu eins sogar
treppen und alles mögliche das ist
einfach ein zu eins geht die
hubschrauber mit ihr mir da auch
glaubtet jetzt nicht sagten du fliegst
nur im flughafen rum ich hab euch blende
ich jetzt einfach mal ein bild an und
lassen dieses bild jetzt erstmal auf
euch wirke hier sehen wir das auch noch
mal dass die hier halt noch ein bisschen
bauen müssen sich jetzt halt gesagt okay
hier kommt eigentlich noch ein flugzeug
internet erstmals eine grundstruktur
quasi mit den ganzen blöcken hier
gezeichnet worden und zwar da hinten ist
sogar schon so nah
guck mal da haben wir sogar schon
flugzeuge walter sieht das cool aus das
ist echt mein lieblings building team
von den ganzen leuten hier
die köln vielleicht nicht so geil bauen
aber die haben mehr ausdauer und
disziplin dabei das ist richtig schön
also ich blende euch jetzt einfach mal
ein bild das dieses bild aufrecht wirken
das ist nämlich die komplette map die
die bisher so gebaut haben ich bin jetzt
hier gerade ja nur beim flughafen ich
versuche mal von dem flughafen jetzt ein
bisschen weg zu kommen und das ist auf
jeden fall alles was die bisher schon
gebaut haben ich fliege jetzt immer so
ein bisschen rum und versuche immer so
ein bisschen aus dem flughafen heraus zu
kommen aber ich muss hier um hier ist
die straße die am flughafen lang führt
und so dann zeige ich euch mal noch ein
bisschen mehr hier alles wo wirklich
diese komischen muster sind da kommen
auf jeden fall noch sachen hin
das ist erstmal so einfach aufgebaut
geworden von denen das die vision im
spitzenspiel also die können sich so
heftig guck mal ich weiß ja wie es kennt
aber diese rampe hier kann man ja da
hinten so rum fahren kann hier da oben
steht doch eigentlich noch sein auto
drauf fällt mir gerade auf hier oben
steht eigentlich so ein auto drauf kann
man hier rumfahren und ansonsten machen
hier oben sehen wir auch sonne sonne
sonne kugel hier am flughafen übrigens
diese personen da hinten
wenn ihr mal schaut dieser kopf da ganz
hinten der verfolgt mich schon die ganze
zeit soll das wiso wieso bist du die
ganze zeit in meiner nähe
was ist was soll das was was was tobi
map seht ihr natürlich immer noch oben
recht eingeblendet dass es einfach so
krass und zwar habt ihr da seid ihr ja
auf der mit meinen kleinen namen und da
will einfach nur ich und das ist einfach
nur ein minimaler teil vom ganzen web
wenn ich jetzt mal so was schaut wenn
ich hier weiter flieger jene diese
ganzen straßen systeme sind auch schon
teilweise fertig also diese ganzen
straßen die hier um führen die ganzen
schilder das wird natürlich alles noch
ein bisschen cooler hier gemacht ich
wollte ich wie gesagt erst mal sonnig
malta wie kannst du deinen zu schauen
erst mal zeigen wie das ganze werden
soll und so einfach damit ihr euch auf
was freuen können aber die brauchen noch
extreme landen weil die wollen einfach
die komplette meppen nachbauen
wir werden dann halt auch noch straßen
kommen die sind jetzt noch nicht fertig
und jetzt sehen wir nämlich mal das was
die noch nicht gebaut haben und zwar
hier sind diese ganzen komischen blöcke
und überall wo diese komischen blöcke
sind kommen nachher andere dinge hin
wenn ihr euch fragt warum das hier zu
hoch ist das dann wahrscheinlich einfach
weil hier noch häuser band ist oder
irgendwie so man könnte jetzt rein
theoretisch wieder auf der map gucken
ihr findet übrigens den link in der
beschreibung wo ihr euch dieses dieses
bild was ich euch über oben rechts
eingeblendet habe einen anschauen könnt
das ist eine interaktive karte
also das ist richtig stark dann habe ich
euch auch noch einen linken der
beschreibung gepackt wo ihr einfach auf
diese server joinen könnt euch das ganze
einfach mal selber anschauen könnt
übrigens ich fliege ganz einfach mal so
ein bisschen rum und euch zu zeigen was
die bisher so als groben foul
8 haben das hier steht dann
beispielsweise für ein etwas höheres
gebäude weil das so ein bisschen höher
geht und so also einfach nur so ein paar
das soll etwas ähnliches gebäude dann da
ist wahrscheinlich kommt dann hochhaus
irgendwie hin weil das was sind schon
hohe gebäude wahrscheinlich bin ich gern
in downtown und da drum rum quasi werden
dann diese hochhäuser gebaut also die
haben sich da echt schon mega viel
gedanken zu dem hier ist
hundertprozentig nachher dieses downtown
mäßige weil wenn hier das werden auf
jeden fall noch hochhäuser und die gehen
natürlich noch höher
also es gibt echt teilweise 80 haben die
map wirklich einfach hier
da genau wird wo wie ich denn gerade
wenn ich jetzt immer von oben schaue mit
little viel co2 wie ich weiß nicht wie
diese stadt ausgesprochen wie das ist
ganz einfach so die haben das ganze
gebaut und dann wenn man auf diese map
nachher draufgeht will die auf den link
in der beschreibung war drauf geht kann
man quasi genau sehen wo man gerade ist
und ich bin hundertprozentig gerade in
dem im hochhausviertel weil hier über
all diese großen gebäude laden die
werden dann natürlich auf jeden fall
noch schöner gemacht dass es erst mal
nur kurz ist die wissen wo die was hin
bauen sollen
aber ihr findet auf jeden fall alles in
der beschreibung findet den link zu der
website denen die server ip hier in der
beschreibung und das war es eigentlich
hier werden dann auf jeden fall in ein
paar wochen monaten vielleicht auch erst
in jahren die besten besten maps die
besten hochhäuser auf irgendeiner map
stehen das möchte jetzt mal was grob
behaupten mit von assassin's creed skin
dass sie ganz cool aus also ich möchte
das wieder und gar nicht so lange halten
ich wollte euch wirklich nur den
fortschritt zeigen wie weit hier sind
und wenn jeder interesse daran haben wie
die leute da bauen oder wenn ihr euch
als bauer bewerben wollte dabei
zusätzlich können einfach mal auf den
weg nach beschreibung klicken bzw
einfach mal hier zäunen ich meine nick
und so immer hier
heinig kann ich einfach mal schreiben
und ich habe die ganze zeit auf 1 hat
deswegen habe ich nie gesehen wenn
jemand mit beschreiben wollte der
antwortet die ganze ganz einfach heiko
kraft uk hallo also da können einfach
mit dem schreiben könne fragen und das
ist fertig wir können an der klatsche
beim schreiben in zwei tagen kommt ein
kleines video
ich wollte euch wirklich einfach nur
ganz kurz zeigen wie weit die hier sind
weil es einfach so geil ist ich würde
sagen es euch gefallen hat und ihr sind
macher unterstützen wollt
beziehungsweise ich ja eigentlich nicht
so gemacht hat sondern euch das nur
gezeigt hat egal gibt daumen hoch und
entscheidet selber wieder modern aber
die links und auf jeden fall eine
beschreibung wenn euch dafür
interessiert ich sagen
und jetzt